to all citizens of the Dominion
on this eve of my last birthday as your
queen let us have one last festivity
together
first body
the Empire Academy is about the
friendship between two young women Rose
and Alyssa as they enter The Adult World
they realize the differences between
them in class might be the thing that
either tears them apart or makes them
change the world together have you ever
met a royal maroy in a high position of
Power with a dampier best friend in this
Dominion there are three distinct
classes the moroy a benevolent mortal
vampire the Don Pierre are raised to
serve the moroy as Guardians they
protect them against the stragoi
immortal bloodthirsty vampires
Rose Hathaway is a dampier she wants to
be the best Guardian yet she questions
why am I doing this I want to protect my
best friend and I want a life to call my
own Melissa dragomir is a royal maroy
vampire she starts off the story really
naive her life kind of gets flipped
upside down put the next heir to the
throne I name that's Alyssa ragamir it's
all very juicy and very dramatic I like
young love I like love triangles I like
the star-crossed lovers there's Alyssa
and Christian he's a royal maroy
unfortunately he is an outcast I heard
you spent a lot of time here books on
gospel about me they sort of have this
spark there's a real love there and a
real genuine connection we shouldn't do
this
I like the love that was not meant to be
I like the love that tears us apart and
Rose and Dimitri embody all of that
Dimitri is an expert Guardian the
chemistry is real you need this fight
Rose I know you're hurting and I'd do
anything to make it stop
one of the great things about this show
is that we have all these amazing fights
you stunt team created something
beautiful it's like a dance you'll see a
lot of precision in skill they're
everything I think everyone wants to see
when you're fighting vampires it's
pretty cool getting to do all the
training and the fighting and it's just
nice to see black girls kicking ass and
being brave and being beautiful and I
live for that I live for that we deserve
a better future moroy and Don Pierre
alike Vampire Academy has something very
profound to say about equality gotten
across in a fun and entertaining way
Vampire Academy has love and romance
it's got royal yumminess it tells
stories of loss and grief but it is also
the origin story of a revolution if this
is the way the world is then maybe it's
the world that needs to change and what
a thrill to be able to tell that kind of
story with two young women at the center
we are all a part of this Dominion
thank you